この字幕は適当ですそれでもいいという人はグットボタン
こんにちわ！（ドヤ）ドクtrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr
今日はとある実験だ。
皆さんネットの記事とか一時期有名になったとおもうんだが…
ハリボーグミ！（召喚）
ガサッ
食べたことありますか？
基本的にコンビニとかにいれば（？）売っている
大人気グミシリーズの一つでございます
だがこのハリボーグミ、とある人が素晴らしい食べ方を発見したようだ
ネットの記事で見たんですけどもこのハリボーグミをウイスキーの中に漬けて
二日間漬け込んだところ
とてもとてもおいしくなってしまった
という記事を昔みたことがあります。
うん...
あの僕、根本的にお酒あまり飲まないんで多分
ウイスキーに漬けたハリボーグミを食うだけでも
多分僕はもう...
(コッコッ
逆に私たちのような人たちはどうやってあれを楽しめばいいのかと考えたところ
わたくしは考えた...
ウイスキー...
濃いじゃないですか！
そこで濃い飲み物は何かあるかなと思ったところ
こちら！
ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯ
ﾜｯﾊｯﾊｯ(ｽｰｯ
ﾜﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯ
ﾊｰｯ!!
大人たちはウイスキーを楽しんでる
俺たちはカルピスを飲む
つまり！
画面まま
倍だぁ...
100時間漬けていたらどれだけおいしくなるか実験してみようと思う
ﾜｰｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｰ(ry
あぁﾔﾍﾞ
まぁ！間違いではない発想だとは思う
カルピスの原液、とても濃いです
あんまり原液って飲んだことないんですよねぇ•••
いただきます！
あ。すごい。相性いいな多分。
ミルク風味のおいしいグミになるんではないかと私は仮定しています
今だとでも小さいんだが、
水を吸うことによってかなり巨大化するらしいので
ネットで見た記事だとだいたい二日間、48時間程度やっていたみたいなんですけれど
私はそれの二倍
100時間！
約四日間くらいを目処にやってみようと思います。
それによってサイズ感がどれくらい変化するかというのと
味がどれだけ、この、浸み込むかというのもわかると思うので
早速！
準備していこうと思う
では行こう！！
あんまり浸しすぎてもダメみたいなので
全部、こう、つかないよ、くらいの量でいいみたいです
あぁ、やべぇ、匂いがすごい。匂いが。
もうこんなもんでいいじゃないかな、多分...
大体これくらいでいいと思います！
では早速、ハリボーグミを置いて行こうと思う！
あれ、これまだちょっと浅いな...
はい！というわけで全部入りました！
このサイズ感！（まるでジャパネット）
このサイズ感！みなさん覚えといてくだ
さい
よし！
いまから100にt...
いまから100時間待ってみようと思います
アデュー！
気づいたらあれから...5日間経っていた...（120時間）
さすがにこれだけグミを水分に浸しておくと
かなりの大きさの変化が見られるのではないかと
思う。
では！
取りにいってこよう！
おーっ！ワォワォワォ！
あれ、待って、待って、なんかすごい
はい。とりあえずちゃんと
成功してるみたいなんですけども
ちょっと不安要素も一つありまして
カルピスの色が明らかおかしいんですよね...
では早速！
取り出してみようと思う！
スプーンですくってもかなりデカめになってます
わぁーなんかすげぇ
プルプルしてる！プルプル！
なんかすごーい！
ユメカワ〜(?)
すごーい！なんかウチ
ユメカw
普通のハリボーグミと比べてもその差は歴然です
では早速食べてみようと思います！
いただきます！
ﾃﾞｭｸｼ
あぁ...
あぁ！
んーっ！
うまぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁい！！
柔らかいそして！
俺これ....
（ドヤァ）
うまい！
これ多分ねぇあれだねぇ
カルピス濃い目で正解だったパターンですね
グミってそんな水分吸収するために
生まれてきましたみたいな役割ではないので
そもそも水分の吸収率自体はそんなに
高いものじゃないと思うんですけども
このわずかに吸収出来そうな水分のところに
凝縮されたカルピスの原液をぶち込むことによって
グミの味とカルピスの
ほどよいハーモニーが奏でられております
チュルチュルって入って
あと柔らかい！
モチモチしてる！
あぁもう食べちゃった...
えぇ！
めっちゃうまい！！
フルーツゼリー...？
あっ！
フルーツゼリーだ！！
ＥＤ